guilty on all counts a jury in
minneapolis convicts
former police officer derek chovin of
murder and manslaughter in the death of
george floyd
go to foxnews.com for the latest i'm
harris faulkner i'm greg gutfeld
i'm janis dean and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday april 21st 2021
i'm lisa brady a renewed push to make dc
a state is headed for a house vote and
probably
for a lot more debate it's the number
one issue for residents of washington dc
if the democrats were sincere about
passing this bill
they would amend the constitution first
i'm chris foster
president biden's infrastructure plan
includes a lot of money aimed at
enticing businesses to go green
this is the push that they're trying to
do and they're trying to throw a lot of
money at it throw a lot of tax
incentives at it
to make that shift going from where we
are now
to all renewable energy we speak with
fox business reporter edward lawrence
and i'm todd pyro i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
it's been over 60 years since alaska and
hawaii
became the 49th and 50th states an
effort to make washington d.c the 51st
is up for a vote again this week in the
u.s house where it passed last year
but then stalled in the senate which had
a republican majority at the time
now the democrats have slim majorities
in both chambers
and a president who supports making d.c
estate
while maintaining a federal district as
the nation's
seat of government we are here to demand
that the 220 year history
of us not being represented in the
capital
of our country be corrected d.c mayor
muriel bowser spoke at a house hearing
in march
she also raised statehood as a security
issue back in january after the breach
of the u.s capitol
suggesting the national guard response
would have been different
if she had control the way a governor
does to call up the guard without
federal permission
the real rally cry though is right on
the d.c license plates
taxation without representation right
now
d.c has two shadow senators and a house
delegate
eleanor holmes norton who sponsored the
bill they have a
delegate to congress republican
congressman james comer of kentucky
is the ranking member of the house
oversight and reform committee
which held that hearing in march and
approved the bill last week
a lot of times when you hear of a
community saying we don't feel like
we're represented
in the nation's capital it's because the
u.s senators and the u.s representative
never go there
members of congress spend over half the
year in washington d.c washington
there's no city in america better
represented in congress
then then washington dc and with respect
to
elections they have three electoral
college votes in the presidential
election so pound for pound
washington dc has more representation in
washington
than any city in america in my opinion
now they don't have voting members of
the house and senate correct i mean it's
they're not allowed to vote their
delegate voting committee and then
they can vote on the house floor on
amendments so
they have some voting rights in fact
miss norton is very
active in the house oversight committee
where i'm the ranking republican she's
very vocal and she votes on
every issue of course the house
oversight committee has jurisdiction
over
washington dc because when we look at
the constitution the constitution gave
congress the authority
to be over washington dc because the
framers of our constitution wanted a
city
independent of any state they were very
clear in that
this issue came up in 1960
and congress settled on a compromise and
the compromise
was we will give washington d.c three
electoral college votes
in the presidential election and that is
in the 23rd amendment
so if the democrats were sincere about
passing this bill
they would amend the constitution first
because when we had the
amendment to create prohibition
then to undo it when they saw it wasn't
working they had to
pass another amendment to repeal
prohibition so there's already a
precedent set
if we don't repeal the 23rd amendment
when
washington d.c becomes a state as this
bill is written they'll have
six electoral college votes three for
being a state and then three
because the 23rd amendment grants
washington d.c electoral college votes
and
you know when when we pointed that out
the democrats said oh well we will fix
it
trust us i don't trust them at all i
mean you look at the
political power grabs that they've tried
to do just this week
make washington dc a 51st state for the
sole purpose of creating two new
democratic senate seats that's what it's
all about two new democratic senate
seats
then they're wanting to stack the
supreme court by creating three or four
new
u.s supreme court seats and you know the
the decisions that joe biden's made
where he bypassed congress like uh
halting construction of the border wall
halting construction of the
keystone pipeline it's just a huge abuse
of power
in in a series of abuses of power well
and
you're not the first republican to argue
that democrats really have a broader
goal of just trying to
create new democratic voters essentially
a new democratic representation
in congress there have been some
republicans in the past though who've
talked about maybe supporting statehood
for puerto rico for instance
is this a case where a deal could be
made
where you do statehood we we threw that
out there but they scoffed at that they
weren't
interested in that primarily because if
you look at puerto rico they're like
washington dc
they have a delegate to congress well
guess what their delegates are
republican so
if if they're delegate to congress is a
republican that means it's possible for
republicans to win in puerto rico
it is impossible for
a republican to win in washington d.c in
fact the last four
republican presidential candidates got
in the single
digits in washington dc the democrat
candidates have gotten over 90 percent
of the vote we you know the terrible
news of walter mondale
passing away vice president mondale he
only won his home state of minnesota and
washington d.c
against ronald reagan so i mean
washington dc
is 100 democrat they're always going to
elect
democrat leaders the democrats in
congress know that
puerto rico on the other hand could go
either way it would be
a swing state well they don't want
another swing state they want to
transform america now and that's that
was the reason jamie raskin
from maryland who's on the oversight
committee who's on the rules committee
today
as i every time i'm trying to fight this
bill he's the major obstacle
he said in an interview about two months
ago that
uh you know it was vital that we
make washington dc d.c estate because
the senate is blocking so much of their
social justice legislation
so there he said it it's all about the
two new democratic senate seats
right and we should be clear that there
are two so-called
shadow senators for d.c right now in the
senate but they
they do not have voting rights in the
senate correct that's correct
okay so they're delicate in the house
has
some rights to the extent of having a
say on amendments and having a say in
committee
but it's not that way in the senate
you've talked though about
options that do exist to expand voting
representation for d.c
residents what what do you mean what do
you mean by that well we could
we could transfer 100 of the part of
washington dc that maryland turned over
to washington dc back to maryland
and then that's the problem solved then
if they feel like
they would be better served if they had
two u.s senators
in their home city then they would have
two senators in maryland and good for
them they're
they're both democrats so i think that
that would solve the problem you know if
you put the virginia park back in
virginia the washington dc
or the maryland park back in maryland
then that would solve the problem
but that's not really what the purpose
of
this bill is all about the purpose is
getting two new democratic citizens
because joe manchin
and sometimes christian cinema is a a
major obstacle to transforming
america into a socialist utopia
that the liberals and progressives want
the biden administration says
this is about fairness not politics
democrats also reject the idea that
retroseeding parts of d.c back to
maryland and virginia
would solve the problem we in dc are not
happy with the way
congress has continually overruled the
locally elected government
on issues that are important to us paul
strauss is one of dc's two
shadow senators on capitol hill and so
we want the kind of states rights that
americans who live in states wants
yes federal representation is a
component but retroceding us to maryland
won't work
we have been a part of maryland separate
and apart from maryland
i should say for a very very long time
the state line that separates us from
maryland dates back to 1790. that's
longer than most of the borders
and so if you think about the
old adage of the chicken in the egg
putting us
back into maryland isn't much different
from trying to put the egg back in the
chicken
it's not going to work out very well for
either the chicken or the egg it's not
what we want it's not what maryland
wants
what about possible statehood for puerto
rico then is that something that
democrats should also support even if it
means republicans
might pick up senate seats from that
frankly i think yes if that's what
the puerto rican people want i support
statehood
and self-determination for puerto rico
as well look puerto rico once had a
republican governor that endorsed donald
trump
it's represented in congress by a
republican resident commissioner who's
their non-voting delegate
they have a shadow senator who they've
appointed one of which is a republican
woman and so there's plenty of
republicans on the island of puerto rico
and if they want to be represented as
full and equal citizens i support that
what would this do the current proposal
to
the number of electoral votes for dc
because
the the 23rd amendment had had basically
given the district three electoral votes
correct
the 23rd amendment gives the federal
seat of government electoral votes
equivalent to the population of the
least populous state so right now the
number of electoral votes dc gets is
tied to wyoming and not its own
population
now that's a fairly academic argument
because dc doesn't qualify for more than
three electoral votes anyway based on
its population
but if the population grew under the
23rd amendment the number of electors
would not
that being said the new state would get
the same number of electoral votes that
the federal district got under the 23rd
amendment
and we simply repeal the 23rd amendment
what would happen and i mean i know
there's a lot of ifs and it's far down
the road
but i'm just thinking what happens if
the effort to repeal
the 23rd amendment fails though like if
that didn't happen
then what would the outcome be then
technically you'd have a a dc
state with three votes and a federal
district with three votes
yeah but not three voters in fact it
would have no voters because
there's uh all of the residential areas
are
out uh the the state legislatures
determine
the way the electors are chosen and for
the district of columbia under the 23rd
amendment congress
accessed the state legislature for the
federal district
and so there is no mechanism for the
choosing of electors in the now empty
federal district
and because of that nobody expects the
23rd amendment
not to be repealed how much do you hear
from dc residents about this is this
something that you
get calls and emails about
it's the number one issue for residents
of washington dc they want the equality
that comes from being the citizens
not just of the united states but of
their own state
and the last year has really made this a
priority
what used to be considered a political
issue has become one of life and death
for example the coronavirus legislation
that began to put relief funds out to
the states
treated the district as a territory not
a state
the problem is the virus is a
microscopic pathogen
it didn't really understand the
geopolitics of it and didn't realize
that we were a territory and not a state
and so instead all we did was lose
resources in the middle of a pandemic
and people died we also saw the
inability to have a governor who could
call out the national guard when we
needed it
delayed our ability to protect our
community and our own national capital
in the january sixth insurrection
and so so many of these issues are not
being a state
have really impacted the health and
safety of d.c residents and
national security to an extent so it's
taken on a new urgency
paul strauss one of dc's two shadow
senators
we thank you very much for your time
thank you
[Music]
this is todd pyro with your fox news
commentary coming up senator bernie
sanders and congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez yesterday introduced a
bill called the green new deal of public
housing
it's an updated version of a bill that
passed the house installed in the then
republican-controlled senate two years
ago
money to repair and clean up the more
than a million public housing units in
the country
there is money for that but not as much
in the infrastructure plan president
biden is trying to sell to congress
there are also a lot of tax incentives
for private businesses to go green
so much money that a lot of ceos support
the president's plan even with a
corporate tax hike
you see the tax incentives and the
grants that the
bible administration is giving can
offset some of the corporate tax rates
fox business reporter edward lawrence
we've heard about the biden
administration want to raise the
corporate tax rate to 28
there might be a compromise at 25 uh
what we're finding if you look at the
american
jobs plan is that there are tax
incentives for
large corporations uh that have this
shift to renewable energy
for example there's 174 billion dollars
in the american jobs plan that's aimed
at electric cars that whole industry
so there could be grants or tax
incentives with part of that money
for the private sector to build charging
stations at their buildings or switch
their entire
fleets to electric which is what amazon
is doing and that's one of the reasons
you might be hearing amazon come out
and saying they support a higher
corporate tax rate because they are
using those
tax incentives on the other side to sort
of offset that so again
it helps large corporations the smaller
companies maybe don't have the resources
um to do that
to make that switch and use that offset
yeah so in the end uh could this end up
being a matter of again the rich getting
richer and the middle middle-class
companies and smaller companies not
being able to take advantage
yeah it certainly looks like a picking
and choosing of who the winners and who
who are not going to be the winners on
this and large corporations
that have the ability to add solar
panels for example
and get those tax credits for it or uh
pay the money for storage devices
for those solar panels to store the
energy that they get
those corporations would would see a
benefit on the tax
on their tax forms uh but smaller
companies that
you know mom-and-pop shops in washington
dc or in des moines iowa don't have the
resources
to do that and get the tax advantage on
the back side the president by now
has the support of coal workers
basically saying look green energy is
going to be inevitable anyway we're not
going to have our coal jobs we may as
well work with you right
yeah some some coal workers the largest
coal miners union the united mine
workers of america came out on monday
and said that they uh they would support
they could
support an infrastructure bill taken up
by congress if it had some changes in it
and one of the changes that they wanted
to see too they wanted to see some
incentives for their unions meaning uh
change some of the rules related to it
so
the preference to hiring these renewable
energy jobs would go to
displaced mine workers um you're also
talking about
uh senator joe manchin coming out and
saying that uh he appeared with the
the union head when they came out and
talked about it saying that you know
west virginians
are kind of like uh other rural states
um you know
they have 2.3 trillion dollar
infrastructure package is what congress
is looking at
and they want to get a portion of that
infrastructure so basically
a mansion is saying you need that human
infrastructure you can't leave anyone
behind
and that includes those coal mine
workers in west virginia and
manchester goes on to say that you know
when you talk about west virginia they
feel like returning veterans
whereas they did the dirty job that
people asked them to do
nobody questioned it in west virginia
they performed that coal
getting the pole out of the ground
mining and processing that coal
and now uh for some reason they feel
like they're being left behind
by some democrats with that switch so
the coal miners union
would like to see in a final version of
the american jobs
plan some incentive for them money for
them
preference and jobs for them and that's
what they're looking for in order for
their support of this
yeah i mean you hear sometimes like oh
you lost your factory job just go learn
how to be a coder or whatever how
how translatable are our skills in the
coal industry to to green
jobs or did i assume training will be
involved here too
there's going to be a lot of training
that's involved here but in the short
term for that transition
the american jobs plan does pay oil
companies directly
to cap old oil and gas wells so that's
sort of a one-time
shot uh that these workers can then go
and do that there's 16 billion dollars
in that plan that would go to to cap
those
wells but again you have to have that
educational period there will be a
transition
uh moving to renewable energies and
those renewable energy jobs do not pay
as well
uh as the jobs now i've seen recent
studies saying that you could make 80
000
as a coal miner but yet the renewable
energy side of that is only at about 45
000 uh so so there's gonna have to be
some leveling that goes on
uh but again the union this particular
union is looking for some incentive
to make that transition yeah i mean this
isn't really part of the
the american jobs plan but how close are
we to having
an infrastructure that actually works
with this green energy i mean how does i
don't know how the electric grid ties
into it i don't know how
we're going to have you know all these
car companies are looking to get out of
the combustible engine business in the
next
decade or two is there are we going to
have enough charging stations
right well so the goal but the biden
administration is that 500
000 charging stations by 2035 i believe
this is 20 30 or 20 35
um but in those you know this this is
the push that they're trying to do and
they're trying to throw a lot of money
at it throw a lot of tax incentives at
it
to make that shift going from where we
are now
to all renewable energy i talked a
little while ago with the head of a a
a clean energy association and she told
me that basically they're trying to make
that shift and they
and they believe that coal and some of
those other existing
uh sort of dirty if you call them um
ways to get energy there's a place for
it in the transition
but then once you transition away from
it they want to phase that
that out going forward so the
infrastructure quite frankly
isn't there i talked to a solar panel
manufacturer as well as a solar panel
installer
and he said the technology just keeps
improving but again you can have a
battery that will power
your refrigerator but it will not
repower your refrigerator
as well as your air conditioning unit so
you have solar panels
if there's clouds or if it's a rainy day
or if it's at night
you know that battery won't hold through
the night so there's going to be some
technology advances that need to happen
there's also going to have to be some
infrastructure that needs to happen to
be able to support
moving this energy around the united
states so it's going to be very
interesting in the future and this money
according to the advised administration
will pay for some of those things
but again in the short term you know
when we're talking short term maybe 10
years
you're going to see job losses on one
side of it before you can get those
renewable jobs to catch up with it
and then you're looking at at a cost
difference you know the jobs you're
losing or higher paying
the jobs you're gaining are lower paying
yeah well at some point you're going to
want this to be self-sustaining and not
have it be subsidized by the federal
government forever and ever at some
point the technology and the costs are
going to have to come back
to where we are now where the consumer
is going to be able to pay a reasonable
rate for their to get their cars around
to keep their houses powered
and that's and that's exactly the goal
but at the moment that's not the case
and you know these charging stations
let's say you put uh more a million more
electric cars on the road where are you
going to get that energy from right now
you're going to get it from coal and
you're going to need more coal more oil
plants more
more various traditional energy sources
in order to power those
uh electric vehicle stations so so there
is an offset here
wind power solar power can't cover the
amount of demand
that's out there for all of this so
there is going to be as i said that
transition
and the body administration trying to
throw government money at this and
government taxes that is to make this
happen but
you know what it does in effect is it
makes these large corporations also more
reliant
on the government because you know let's
take amazon for example that's moving
their
fleet towards electric that's the way
they're going but they're using
the tax incentives on the other back
side to offset corporate taxes that they
might pay
well they need to keep those tax
incentives going we need the government
to continue to offer those
and continue to offer grants in order to
sort of keep a baseline profit
uh to go forward so so it does create a
more
reliance on bigger government yeah uh
republicans in congress
have said over and over again look this
supposed infrastructure agenda is
very little of it is infrastructure i
mean some of it's debatable some of it's
clearly not um if if you could pull
aside
pull away some of the green stuff from
this
could a lot of it get bipartisan support
what are a lot of republicans in
congress saying about
the inevitability of moving toward this
kind of energy
and the answer is yes you can have
bipartisan support if you pull out
the traditional infrastructure stuff out
of the american jobs plan
you probably will get bipartisan support
senator
cornyn from texas has come out and said
that he could see an 800 billion dollar
plan
not the 2.25 trillion dollar plan an 800
billion dollar plan that focuses on
that traditional infrastructure roads
bridges um you know in even
the internet broadband cable uh to all
communities and upgrading that
that could get bipartisan support here
uh so we'll have to see the negotiations
are happening now
we are seeing senator chris coons from
delaware also coming out
and saying he could support a smaller
800 billion dollar package that has just
infrastructure in it but the other side
of that is and senator chris coons
alluded to this
is that they could then take all the
rest of the stuff and use the
reconciliation process
and just ram that through without
republican support right all right well
we'll see
what happens with it uh fox business
networks edward lawrence edward thanks
for coming on
thanks chris appreciate it
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon bream host of fox news at
night and author of the new book
women of the bible speak the wisdom of
16 women and their lessons for today
subscribe now on apple podcast spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts it's time for
your fox news commentary
todd pyro what's on your mind
six weeks or as the team on fox and
friends first called it the spring of
todd
playing off the old seinfeld episode
called the summer of george
where the character george costanza
plans an activity filled three months
away from work that
ultimately ends with him failing to
leave his apartment i told the first
team
mostly parents themselves about all the
tasks i was going to
accomplish during my paternity leave
they laughed
and mocked me for my naivete and even
though i knew they were probably correct
that i would get none of my tasks done
i didn't know how correct they would
prove to be
finally watch mad men ha some days i
didn't have time to turn on the tv
streamline my contacts list the only
contact i contacted
was my wife and that was to ask where do
i put that cream
how do i tell the difference between the
different cries and
why is there a color wheel for what
comes out of this child
follow a workout regimen of running and
flexibility training
the only running i did was to heat up
bottles to soothe a screaming child
and the only flexibility i demonstrated
was the incessant one-handed bend
to pick up the pacifier thrown to the
floor approximately 20
times a day and you know what i wouldn't
change a thing
because if i did one thing correctly in
my anticipation of leave it was to
remind myself
to enjoy the ride when i look back on
high school and college
i regret that i was so focused on the
end goal that i didn't appreciate the
journey
thanks to the benefits of wisdom that
come with getting older i wasn't going
to make that mistake
again that doesn't mean the ride is easy
and every parent knows that some of my
favorite
observations when you are not changing
or feeding your kid
you are performing a constant song and
dance routine where you inject your
child's name into every third word of
the music
and jump around your kitchen like an
inebriated uncle at a wedding
a flailing of body parts and creepy
clown face expressions that somehow
is the greatest sight in your baby's new
life every single time you do it
the nose freda if you know what it is
you understand
if you don't please don't look it up
just maintain your innocence as long as
you can
baby shark works it just does i don't
know why
i don't know how i don't care but my
favorite observation from the past six
weeks
needs no witty description it's simply
watching love
unfold before your eyes a loving her
eyes for you
a love for her and a part of your heart
you didn't know existed
it's a love where everything you say is
the funniest
and if you've ever seen fox and friends
first not everything i say is as funny
as i think it is
just as my co-anchor jillian it's a love
where even the vilest of tasks
are ones you know you will miss one day
maybe not tomorrow
maybe not six months from now but one
day
it's a love we're boxing up the infant
clothes that she has already grown out
of
causes you to weepily whale butterfly
kisses around the house
okay even my wife makes fun of me for
that and it's a love that makes the
challenges of our times
100 worth it i cannot thank fox enough
for providing all fathers who work here
with such a generous paternity leave
this experience has changed me in a
profound way
and in ways i won't fully comprehend
until my daughter is older
but for now that smile coming from the
crib each morning immediately followed
by morning snuggles
is what i will cherish the most there is
nothing better
and while it may not have been the
spring of todd it was without a doubt
the time of my life i'm todd pyro fox
news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes